you farted right now this entire fall
smell like a garden today we are here at
bi coffee in Koreatown Los Angeles and
we are here to try the soon-to-be world
famous flower coffee
[Music]
what is it it's coffee that apparently
peace like fart flowers are delightful
they're colorful they smell nice I
actually like dead flowers I keep a lot
of them in my rooms like Pretz flowers
are just straight-up like wilted I know
we have like the rose bushes that eat
I'd like trying and I was always
disappointed never ate a flower but I
like them always dreamed about eating
flowers as a kid there's so much cool
stuff going on here rosebuds floating in
that full bud burger don't taste like a
rose that's [ __ ] crazy very
refreshing like I've had like some like
drinks that have had like rosewater in
it yeah that doesn't even taste as much
like a rose like this does sometimes um
cold brew is too bitter for me but this
has like that little like floral
aftertaste is really nice you think kind
of like they just taste like plants it
actually tastes like a rose and I don't
know what that means
I've is just like chugging yeah like
this is so good damn this one's so
pretty I don't want to mess it up I feel
like I am sitting inside of someone's
Instagram I don't want to stir it it
looks so pretty
okay ready oh it's so good there's like
coffee some sweetness creamy floral
gorgeous heaven
you know sometimes like coffee is just a
little heavy or too strong or whatever
this is just delight it tastes like a
French flower shop this isn't like any
coffee I've had before this is seriously
some freshness going on here these
drinks keep getting more and more
elaborate got a little rose petal on it
and I will endorse it I feel so fancy I
just ate a rose petal all right I'm not
here's a game-changer heaven are you
pretty happy half-and-half makes it an
Italian soda look how beautiful that is
okay that's sweet yeah but that rosy
sort of floral like in your sinuses like
coming through
Tyler cream it's different right I'm
calling a nice smooth uh better actually
I would say it's the sweetest drink that
we've had so far oh my god though it's
like better than any other soda you know
your kid is New Year's
yeah like also drinking champagne I
think this is what I thought the
champagne taste is like I wish this is
what champagne tasted like who knew that
so many things could be flowers we're
missing from so many drinks tastes great
and it's pretty that's like meeting a
guy who's smart and attractive rare this
is like laughing hey this screams luxury
to me look at that
hmm please welcome flower damn yeah I
mean dang so light yeah it looks so
heavy and thick well really creme
fraiche is like so oh my god this one's
so good the texture feels a little bit
like a carrot cake it's light fluffy if
you like lavender and I may taste live
in there this is the fool you get I
could eat that entire thing well this
place is the greatest place on earth
very refreshing
I love flower coffee cold brew with the
rose infusion is just so good you chug
yours in like ten seconds I feel like a
princess unicorn that has a great
Instagram I feel like this is gonna be
like the course for my entire wedding
like everyone's just gonna drink and eat
flower and fuse things forever all the
drinks all the cake they taste exactly
what it smells like it just tasted like
actually what you think flowers would
taste like distilled and not like a
weird syrupy version of it I know just
come in wearing some shorts and just be
like to the normals what we just had
today three drinks on a slice of cake
flowers are no flowers you know what
flowers just put them in stuff
you
[Music]